Good I put my mind to it and when my dead brother's spirit comes out
, I think it was a lie fish Honjo To the
European-style mintai oh
Please do your best
I'm sending my apprentice in a hurry
[music]
Thank
you g too  What's wrong,
I also have school and a private life, so please stop calling me out of the blue My
private life is at most a muscle training club, is
n't it Clay?
I
know what you've been doing with your classmates, are they people who understand you?
Sho You're able to control your own power thanks to me.
Hey, you're enjoying making fun of weak people in your heart
.
Mr. What are you talking about?
I'm tired. Let's eat some ramen and go home
.